YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
MARK STEYN DID THE TEST.
HERE'S WHAT HE LOOKED LIKE
YESTERDAY DOING THE TEST.
♪ ♪
>> Mark: HEY, YOU DON'T WANT
THAT MUSIC MEANS!
ITS "FINAL EXAM" WHEN WE
DISCOVER WHO HAD FOX HAS BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO THE NEWS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN, THOUGH, LET'S
TAKE A QUOTE, QUICK LOOK AT LAST
WEEK'S EXAM, WHICH WAS A FIASCO!
AS SOON AS TUCKER ASKED ABOUT
HER MANAGER THE QUEEN  .
>> WHICH MEMBER OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY HAD THE WORLD IN
HYSTERICS THIS WEEK WHEN HE OR
SHE JOKINGLY COMPARED A NOISY
HELICOPTER TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND OBAMA?
>> QUEEN WHAT'S HER FACE.
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS DIAMOND AND
SILK.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
SPEAK OF THE SITTING U.S.
SENATOR JUDY THIS WHILE IN
OFFICE...
>> YOU DIDN'T WAIT FOR HIM TO
FINISH.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A
TECHNICALITY.
WE WILL THROW IN ONE MORE BONUS
QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE CAPITAL OF
BURKINA FASO?
>> CAN I CHIME IN FOR SEXUAL
PANDAS?
>> Tucker: JEFF, THAT WAS
AMAZING.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Mark: AND YOU THOUGHT STEVE
HARVEY IS MISS UNIVERSE WAS A
FIASCO.
HIS NAME IS ACTUALLY BRETT AND
HERS IS KATIE.
I'M GOING TO KEEP THE TRADITION
AND CALL HIM JEFF AND I'M GOING
TO CALL KT QUEEN WHAT'S HER
FACE.
[LAUGHTER]
I TAKE THAT PERSONALLY.
JEFF MASQUERADES AS BRETT FROM
FOX NEWS HEADLINES 24/7.
WE WELCOME BACK FROM A REMATCH.
WE HAD PROBLEMS, THE
INTERNATIONAL QUIZ SHOW
ARBITRATION COMMITTEE IN GENEVA
SAID THIS ONE WOULDN'T PASS
MUSTER.
BRETT LARSON IS BACK WITH KATIE
FRANK, EDITOR IN CHIEF OF "THE
DAILY WALKER."
HANDS ON BROTHERS.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE QUESTIONS
AND THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ GETS
TO ANSWER.
YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
ASKING THE QUESTION.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH ONE
POINT.
GET IT WRONG, YOU LOSE A POINT,
AND THE BEST OF FIVE WINS.
LET'S GET STARTED.
QUESTION ONE, THIS WEEK, AFTER A
33 YEAR DROUGHT, AN AMERICAN
WOMAN ONE WHICH U.S. SPORTING
EVENT?
LET'S GO TO BRETT.
>> THE BOSTON MARATHON.
>> Mark: C, ROLL TAPE.
>> BECOMING THE FIRST WOMAN TO
WIN THEM BOSTON MARATHON SINCE
1985.
>> Mark: FANTASTIC!
YOU GOT THAT!
>> I JUMPED THE GUN LAST TIME.
>> Mark: TERRIFIC.
QUESTION TWO, THIS WEEK AT THE
NATIONAL ZOO IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., A BABY ANIMAL
WAS BORN.
BIG NEWS BECAUSE HE IS PART OF
AN ENDANGERED SPECIES.
SO WHAT KIND OF ANIMAL IS HE?
>> WHERE IS STEVE IRWIN?
>> NOT A PANDA.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHY DOES THIS HAPPEN EVERY
WEEK?
>> CAN I CALL A FRIEND?
>> Mark: A SIMIAN IS NOT A
RUMINANT, THAT IS COMING UP
LATER.
A BIG THING.
>> YEAH, YEP.
>> SHE'S GOING FOR THE GAS!
>> AND ORANGUTAN?
>> Mark: ODDLY SPECIFIC, IS
THAT CORRECT?
>> OH, BABY.
A NEW STAR IS BORN OF THE
NATIONAL ZOO AFTER A WESTERN
WALL LAND GORILLA GIVES BIRTH.
MOTHER AND BABY DOING JUST FINE.
VIDEO OF THEIR BONDING FIRMS OF
THE INTERNET.
>> SO CUTE, THOUGH.
>> Mark: WESTERN WALL LAND
GORILLA.
SO, BRETT IS STILL IN THE LEAD.
THERE IS A NEW CONDIMENT IN TOWN
AND FOLKS SEEM TO BE VERY
DIVIDED OVER THIS.
HINES IS RELEASING A PREMIXED
MAYONNAISE AND KETCHUP PRODUCT
FOR YOUR SUMMER BARBECUE IS.
BUT WHAT ARE THEY NAMING THIS
LETHAL COMBO?
BRETT?
>> KETCHUNAISE?
>> MAYOCHUP -- I CAN'T EVEN SAY
IT.
HINES TWEETING, "WE HEARD YOU,
SAUCY AMERICANS, WE ARE BRINGING
YOU THE VERSION OF THE DUO YOU
HAVE BEEN EATING FOR YEARS.
>> Mark: YOU WERE SO CLOSE.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
CALLED IT!
>> Mark: I'M WITH YOU.
>> IT IS SO MUCH BETTER.
>> Mark: HOLD THE MAYOCHUP.
JOE BIDEN, QUESTION FOUR, AND
BRETT IS TAKING THE COMMANDING
LEAD HERE.
>> OUT TO ZERO.
>> Mark: JEFF, QUESTION FOUR,
JOE BIDEN ISN'T THE ONLY MEMBER
OF THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERING A 2020 RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
WHICH OTHER MEMBER OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CONFESSED THIS
WEEK HE IS ALSO THINKING OF
RUNNING?
BRETT?
>> I THINK THAT GOES TO QUEEN
WHAT'S HER NAME.
IT >> Mark: ITS KATIE.
>> ERIC HOLDER?
>> EARLIER THIS WEEK, HOLDER
SAID THIS ABOUT A POSSIBLE RUN.
>> YOU ARE CONSIDERING IT?
>> I'M THINKING ABOUT IT.
I HAVE NOT MADE ANY
DETERMINATIONS.
FOCUSING ON THE WORK I'M DOING
WITH THE NATIONAL DEMOCRATIC,
WORKING WITH GERRYMANDERING.
>> Mark: SO THE SCORE RIGHT
NOW IS 0-0.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I AM SO SORRY, 24/7 NEWS
TEAM.
>> Mark: JEFF HAS GOT ZERO AND
QUEEN WHAT'S HER NAME HAS GOT TO
ZERO.
A NEW FAD IS SWEEPING THE
NATION, AND IT INVOLVES DOING
YOGA WITH A FARM ANIMAL.
WHICH FOUR LEGGETT ANIMAL IS
BEING USED IN AMERICAN YOGA
CLASSES?
KATIE?
>> GOATS?
>> Mark: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE TAPE.
>> GOAT YOGA, WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE, LOTUS POSES
AND DOMESTICATED GOATS.
BUT IS IT GOOD FOR AMERICA OR
AMERICA'S GOATS?
>> THERE IS NOTHING INHERENTLY
WRONG WITH DOING THE DOWNWARD
DOG POSE NEXT TO A GOAT.
>> I LOVE GOATS!
>> Mark: WE HAVE A WINNER!
>> CONGRATULATIONS FOR WINNING
THIS TIME.
>> Mark: A GENUINE VICTORY.
WE HAVE THIS MUG.